[Musique]
les poils potables sont extrêmement
rares c'est tellement rare et peu
visible et peu de quartier ah non du
coup lorsqu'il y a un point comme
celui-ci tout le monde se précipite et
déjà même vous avez vu les difficultés
que les gens en ont pour puiser ici
c'est une bagarre c'est un combat c'est
un combat dont ce n'est pas du tout
facile
et l'eau n'est pas potable là-bas donc
nous préférons voyager pour venir
chercher de l'eau potable
[Musique]
le choix du site se fait avec les études
géophysiques qui nous indiquer un point
là où il fallait forêt c'est là que nous
avons positionné la machine pour le
faire nous allons parler de 50 mètres 50
à 70 mètres pour la nappe donc c'est ça
que nous partons chez comme ça
[Musique]
certains ouvrages ne sont pas réalisés
suivant les règles de la des ouvrages
qui ne sont pas faits à des profondeurs
requises ou qui ont
aux alentours des possibles points de
contamination
[Musique]